ومدون معروف فقد حياته في تفجير احد
المقاهي في مدينه سامبرسبرج الروسيه حسب
وزاره الداخليه لم تتبنى حتى الان اي جهه
مسؤوليه الانفجار كما لم تقدم السلطات اي
تفاصيل عما قالت ان سببه هو قنبله كانت
بحوزه احد رواد المقهى لكن مقاطع ما قبل
لحظات من التفجير اظهرت تتارسكي وهو يحمل
تمثالا صغيرا قدم له من احد رواد المقهى
يبدو بانها هي تلك القنبله التي تسببت
بالحادثه بحسب وسائل اعلام روسيه
مصدر في قوه الامن لوكاله التاسع قال بان
قوه العبوه الناسفه تجاوزت 200 جرام من
ماده تي ان تي وبحسب منظم الحدث داخل
المقهى فان الاجراءات الامنيه الضعيفه
سمحت بوقوع التفجير
لكن السر يكمن في خفايا المقهى المتضرر من
التفجير فهو مقهى تعود ملكيته لقائد
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه حسب اعلام
روسي
والابرز شخصيه الصحفي المستهدف فمقاطع
فيديو سابقه للمراسل الحربي المقتول يظهر
فيها وهو يردد عبارات تحريضيه
تشير الى انه مؤيد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الا انه ينتقد استراتيجيه
الجنرالات في وزاره الدفاع كما يفعل قائده
مؤسس فاجنر
سنهزم الجميع وسنقتل الجميع وسنسلب كل من
يحتاج الى السرقه وسيكون كل شيء كما نحب
مقهى سامر يعد ثانيه اهم حادثه بعد سابقه
لها العام الماضي اودت بحياه داريا دوغينا
ابنه الكسندر دوجن الفيلسوف الروسي المقرب
من الرئيس بوتين في انفجار سياره يشتبه
بانها كانت ملغمه روان حمزه العربيه